[Music]
drones are massively popular right now
so popular that it's easy to forget
where the RC craze originally started we
have cars so it's with more than a
little nostalgia that we took command of
the RR ten bomber from axial this RC
off-roader was built for crawling over
rock-strewn across the gnarliest trails
[Music]
it's actually modeled after real-life
behemoths the one-tenth scale replica of
the design by an off-road master Randy
slauson he designs and builds full-size
chassis for offroad racing vehicles that
are able to crawl over massive boulders
at record speed this little Ballmer
performs like the original ripping over
and through with varied terrain while
most rookie RC drivers will be able to
handle the tough stuff right away it'll
take some practice and experience to be
able to tackle more challenging terrain
[Music]
beginners may also be tricked into
thinking their skills I've actually
improved after 30 to 40 minutes of
driving but by then the battery will
started to the feet and the car won't
have as much power to throw himself into
a role as on
that said the controller is simple and
intuitive which makes crushing your way
over boulders around steep gullies and
up gravel trails a lot easier than you
think
[Music]
Oh